♪ ♪
>> Mike:
>> Iike:
>> IFke:
>> IF E:
>> IF EVIL IS GOING TO DO
SOMETHING HORRIBLE, EVIL IS
GOING TO DO SOMETHING HORRIBLE.
>> THE SUSPECT IS DECEASED,
THANKS TO THE QUICK ACTIONS OF
THE MEMBERS INSIDE THE CHURCH.
>> WE WON'T STAND FOR US, IN
NEW YORK CITY WE WILL NOT ALLOW
ATTACKS ON THE JEWISH COMMUNITY.
>> IT'S THE LITTLE THINGS AND IT
GETS WORSE.
NEVER AGAIN IS BEING TAKEN
SERIOUS RIGHT NOW.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T GET INTO
A SPITEFUL MINORITIES BLAMING
OTHER MINORITIES.
>> WHY DID YOU DO IT?
>> Mike: AN UGLY HOLIDAY
WEEKEND OF RELIGIOUS VIOLENCE
AND LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
RECENT TIMELINE OF ATTACKS IN
NEW YORK AND ANTI-SEMITIC
ATTACKS IN NEW YORK.
OF TWO INCIDENTS ON
DECEMBER 23RD, 1 DECEMBER 20
DECEMBER 23RD, 1 DECEMBER 24TH,
AND AN ORTHODOX JEWISH MAN WAS
CHASED ON THE STREET AND TRADE
DUMB I PUNCHED IN THE FACE.
A JEWISH MOTHER AND THAT HER SON
WERE ATTACKED BY A WOMAN WHO
YELLED ANTI-SEMITIC SLURS AND
PUNCH THE MOTHER IN THE HEAD.
AT TWO INCIDENTS ON
DECEMBER 27TH AND THE WORST OF
THEM ALL, THE MAN ENTERING THE
HOME OF A RABBI ON THE HANUKKAH
CELEBRATION AND BEGAN STABBING
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE NUMBERS IN TERMS OF THE
ANTI-SEMITIC HATE CRIME
INCIDENTS FROM THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE.
OF 2016, 1206 TO SEVEN, 2017 IT
SEARCHED IN 1986.
2018, ANOTHER HIGHLY NUMBER,
2019, AND TODAY, 1347.
1347.
ALTHOUGH PARTICULARLY UGLY
STRETCH IN NEW YORK RECENTLY.
IT LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
OF COURSE IS A POLITICS EDITOR
HERE AT FOX NEWS.
IT CHARON, AN OPINION WRITER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
TOM, YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> OFFICE LATE, IT'S VERY
DISTURBING AND IT'S GOOD TO SEE
FOLKS ARE BRINGING ATTENTION TO
THIS AND CALLING IT OUT.
IF IT'S HARD TO SAY WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TWO ATTACKS, IT'S
THE MOTIVATIONS OF THE PEOPLE
AND AS PEOPLE SAID, IT'S EVIL AD
THERE'S NOT A LOT THAT CAN BE
DONE.
IT'S A GOOD TO FOCUS ATTENTION
ON IT.
DO WHATEVER CAN BE DONE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THINGS DO,
GOOD TO SEE THAT OTHERS DESPITE
WE HAVE A SEARCH RECENTLY, THAT
THEY'RE COMING DOWN.
>> SECURITY OF STATE SAYS IT'S A
RELIGIOUS PROBLEM AROUND THE
GLOBE.
>> WE HAVE SEEN AN INCREASE IN
ANTI-SEMITISM AROUND THE WORLD
AND WE'VE OBSERVED CHRISTIANS
UNDER THREATS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
IF IN OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD
AS WELL.
IT PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE A TRUE
PILLAR OF AMERICANS OF FOREIGN
POLICY AND THE FRUIT THOUGH MIKE
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM TO PRACTICE
OUR FAITH THE WAY WE DESIRE TO
DO SO.
>> Mike: YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> IT'S NOT JUST THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF ANTI-SEMITIC ATTACKS
THAT WE ARE SEEING, BUT IT'S
SORT OF THE SIZE AND THE
AGGRESSIVENESS.
WE ARE A YEAR OUT FROM THE
HORRIFIC MASSACRE AT THE
SYNAGOGUE AND AGAIN, YOU WONDER,
EVERYONE DENOUNCES THEM BUT AT
WHAT POINT ARE WE GOING TO SORT
OF SPOT THESE PEOPLE BEFORE A
THEY CARRY OUT THE HORRIFIC ACT
ACTS?
>> Mike: CHRIS, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> IT'S THE CHEAPEST AND EASIEST
POINT OF DIVISION FOR
HUMAN BEINGS RIGHT AFTER RACE
AND THAT'S THE EASIEST ONE.
THE NEXT POINT THAT YOU CAN GIVE
PEOPLE, YOU CAN PULL PEOPLE
APART IS ON THEIR GRADE.
THAT'S WHAT HE BELIEVES THIS
WAY, AND IT'S PART OF HUMAN
NATURE AND THAT SADLY WILL BE
WITH US.
THE QUESTION IS, HOW ARE PEOPLE
OF GOOD FAITH, THE QUESTION HOW
ARE DECENT PEOPLE RESPONDING AND
WHAT DOES THE RESPONSE?
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD BE PROUD
OF IS THAT ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND EVERY CORNER FROM EVERY RACE
COLLATED CREATED, RACE,, THE
ANSWER COMES ACROSS AND IT'S
UNACCEPTABLE.
IT'S TOTALLY UNACCESSIBLE.
>> Mike: IN THE FORT WORTH,
TEXAS, AREA WHERE GUN PACKING
PARISHIONERS STOPPED IT FROM
BEING A WHOLE LOT WORSE.
OF TIME.
>> THIS IS THE STORY THAT YOU
HEAR ABOUT IT, THE GOOD GUYS
WITH GUNS.
THANK GOODNESS THERE WERE PEOPLE
THERE AND WHO KNOWS HOW MANY
OTHER PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE DONE HAD
THEY NOT TAKEN ACTION.
A BACK TO CHRIS'S POINT, IT'S
ALSO THE SIT DOWN SIDE TO THIS
UNFORTUNATELY IS THAT IT BECOMES
POLITICAL.
YOU SOLVED
YOU BOLVED
YOU BILVED
YOU BILL D
YOU BILL de BLASIO, TRY TO
BLAME WHAT THE PRESIDENT
HAPPENED, AND THAT THE
ANTI-SEMITIC HATE IT WHEN THE
PRESIDENT CAME UP WITH A PRETTY
STRONG AND AGGRESSIVE STATEMENT
ON THIS.
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO PLAY
POLITICS WITH US AS WELL.
>> Mike: FROM GOVERNOR CUOMO
OF NEW YORK.
AT THE SOUND BITE.
>> THEY SHOULD BE PROSECUTED AS
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
IF THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE.
IF I WANT THE STATE TO BE THE FR
IF I WANT THE STATE TO BE THE FT
STATE TO HAVE THE DOMESTIC
TERRORISM LAW.
TO EXPRESS HOW IGNORANT THIS IS,
HOW INTOLERANT IT IS.
HOW CRIMINAL IT IS.
>> Mike: WHAT ABOUT THAT
SUGGESTION OF DOMESTIC TERRORISM
PROSECUTION?
>> AGAIN, WE STILL DON'T KNOW
THE MOTIVATIONS HERE.
FOR INSTANCE, IN TEXAS, WE ARE
JUST LEARNING ABOUT THE SHOOTER.
THIS WAS A MAN WHO HAS
APPARENTLY, ARRESTS RECORD IN
THREE STATES INCLUDING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AGAIN, WE NEED TO SORT OUT WHAT
THE ACTUAL MOTIVATIONS ARE
BEFORE REBRANDING THESE THINGS.
ANOTHER THING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKED ABOUT IS
THAT USING THE CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS
TO CRACK DOWN ON THIS.
THERE IS SOME APPEAL TO THAT I
GUESS, BUT THERE'S ALSO PEOPLE
WHO ARE WORRIED, JEWISH LEADERS
WHO ARE WORRIED THAT YOU ARE
SORT OF SINGLING OUT WHAT IS THE
RELIGION AND BRANDING IT A RACE
OR A NATIONALITY.
THERE ARE JUST ALL KIND OF
COMPLICATED ISSUES THAT YOU
START WADING INTO A PERIOD OF
>> Mike: YOU CALL THIS A HATE
CRIME AND THIS, TERRORISM.
OF THE SAME THING, IT'S ALWAYS
TRUE AND PEOPLE IN THE
SITUATIONS NEED TO BE
INSTITUTIONALIZED AND SOME WE
STOPPED IN ADVANCE TO.
IT SOMETHING AFTERWARDS MAY BE
HELPED HIM WHEN YOUR VOTES,
DONALD TRUMP ONE VOTES, I DON'T
KNOW, THE SOLUTIONS ARE THE SAME
WHATEVER YOU CALL THEM.
>> Mike: SPEAKING OF THE
PRESIDENT, PLAY WHEN HE HAD TO
SAY ABOUT THIS BEFORE THE RECENT
WAVE IN NEW YORK.
>> MY EXECUTIVE ORDER PROHIBITS
THE FEDERAL FUNDING TO ANY
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY THAT
SPREADS, PROMOTES, TOLERATES, OR
SUPPORTS ANYTHING HAVING TO DO
WITH ANTI-SEMITIC
WITH ANDI-SEMITIC
WITH AND ESEMITIC
WITH AND ESTMITIC
WITH AND ESTIMTIC
WITH AND ESTIMATC
WITH AND ESTIMATE IT OF THEM.
OF ANTI-SEMITISM.
>> IF THEY WANTED THEY THAT,
IT'S GOING TO BE EXTREMELY
FRUSTRATING AND IT'S AMAZING HOW
QUICKLY THEY STOP.
OF >> Mike: HERE WE ARE AT THE
END OF CHRISTMAS AND AT THE END